Last time,
I believe I said I wanted to discuss three
features that Tocqueville regarded as
central to American democracy
that is not just study.
They were central to the
democratic experience.
Uh,
but they are central features of the
American Democrat Democratic experience.
And to what degree these can be or
could possibly be translated to other
contexts in other emerging democracies
remains very much an open question.
But of these three features,
uh,
the first,
talked a little bit about on Monday
is the importance of local government,
uh,
the township as it's translated in,
in,
in this,
in this edition.
What Tocqueville cause the
commune that community,
community,
Spirit,
local government,
um,
in some way connected to what
he calls later in the book,
uh,
the spirit of the city using the city in
the here and the context of the ancient
sense of Polis lists breed the city,
that spirit of a kind of Polish
like character in these small,
New England townships,
very important.
Uh,
Tocqueville believes,
uh,
for the,
sustaining a democratic country
in a democratic society.
But the second and probably the aspect
of Tocqueville's account of democratic,
uh,
America that has received the
most attention at least recently,
uh,
is,
the aspect of what he calls throughout
the Book Civil Association Civic
Association.
It is these,
uh,
what one might think of
as intermediary groups,
voluntary groups,
civic organizations of
all kinds that have,
uh,
that that Tocqueville is,
is immensely impressed with and which
he turns into one of the central pillars
of the democratic experience.
He writes that in democratic countries,
uh,
one of the most famous sentences,
from the book in democratic countries,
the Science of association he
says is the Mother's science.
The progress of all the others
depends on the progress of that one.
And it is through uniting and
joining together in common endeavors.
He believes that people
develop a taste for liberty.
It taste for freedom in America.
If I can just quote him again.
In America,
I encountered all sorts of associations
of which I confess I had no idea.
And I often admired the infinite art
with which the inhabitants of the United
States managed to fix a common goal to
the efforts of many men to get them to
advance,
freely struck by the immense variety and
multiplicity and sheer number of these
various kinds of civic association.
And it doesn't,
it is important to see perhaps
this is one area in which,
uh,
Tocqueville's teams to most
clearly depart from Roussel,
at least the root cell
of this social contract.
After having said last time that his
account of local democracy township
democracy owes so much to Russo's
account of the general will.
But remember that Rousseau
in the social contract,
he did invade against warned against
what he called partial associations.
Uh,
partial associations like interest groups
of various kinds and have the tendency
to frustrate a,
the general will that stand as it were
between the individual and the general
will.
But Tocqueville,
on the other hand regards these
kinds of voluntary associations,
associations of all sorts.
It's precisely the place where
we learn habits of initiative.
A cooperation and
responsibility with others.
By taking care of our own interests
or the interests of our association.
We learn to take care of
the interests of others.
Sentiments and ideas renew themselves.
Tocqueville writes,
the heart is enlarged and
the human mind is developed.
So he puts,
you can see from a passage like that
how much weight he puts on these civic
associations.
The heart is enlarged,
the mind is developed.
It is through these associations,
PTA,
churches,
synagogues and other civil bodies and
association that institutions are formed
that can both resist in its way
the power of centralized authority,
central government.
But they are also the,
is it where the locus,
the seed bed where citizens
learn to become demo,
where we learn to become
democratic citizens.
It's very much important for
Tocqueville that these associations,
uh,
which the absence of which he
felt very acutely in France,
uh,
which had already become
a highly centralized,
uh,
society.
Uh,
it was these,
uh,
these,
these intermediary voluntary associations
that stand between the individual and,
and central authority,
the authority of the national government,
which,
which is what makes them
so important for him.
And this argument about the
importance of civic association.
I say it has become a,
in a way the most talked about past edge
or a part of the book in recent years.
This is due in large part to the influence
of political scientist Robert Putnam.
Uh,
a man who teaches at another university,
uh,
called,
called a book called Bowling alone.
You've probably maybe heard of that and
hear Putnam speaks about what he calls
human capital.
Uh,
what Tocqueville,
uh,
in,
in less obviously science,
less social scientific jargon because
habits of the heart mores habits of the
heart,
mind and heart.
But Putnam argues that it is this social
capital that is developed through civic
association and its chief example as the
title of the book in the article from
which it draws,
suggests it said the bowling league,
it's a kind of model of civic association
and particularly he is concerned with
the decline of these associations
in contemporary American life.
Hence the title of the Book Bowling alone.
The fact that Tocqueville himself
describes these civic associations is the
product of art suggest that that is
to say that they are not natural.
They are not,
uh,
somehow uh,
the result of um,
uh,
some kind of instinctual behavior on us.
They are joining with others in voluntary
associations is a learned activity.
Uh,
it is something that requires a certain
kind of culture and that end is a
learned activity.
It is something also it is an artist,
his skill,
it is a craft that can also be lost.
And his argument is that more
and more people are so to speak,
choosing to bowl,
bowl alone,
uh,
something that shows an alarming tendency
towards isolation and the subsequent
kind of a depletion or most
of our civic capacities.
Uh,
the question is have our uh,
taking Tocqueville to the prison,
have our capacities for
joining with others being
eroded by the forces of modern
politics and technology are in fact we
becoming more and more a nation of solid,
solitary and,
and couch potatoes.
Jude,
can I get you here for just a minute?
These are some of the serious questions
and there is a big literature,
uh,
that has grown up around it.
And some of this literature,
uh,
finds Putnam's,
conclusions to be overdrawn,
uh,
that he exaggerates
the influence of these,
uh,
associations did or the
decline of these associations.
Uh,
I'll tell you this,
when these associations,
and in fact,
uh,
our civic state is not as
bad off as he suggests,
but what I want to do suggest today,
and this is where I'm going to show a
film and June is going to help me just a
couple of clips,
is that there is a serious question,
I think in my mind,
whether bowling leagues are a proper
model for Democratic Association,
uh,
now one can say and using the title
bowling alone that Putnam is just speaking
metaphorically,
that,
uh,
he's not really doesn't mean bowling
leagues and because you use it using it as
a metaphor,
but let's take him at his
word and let's find out a,
if bowling leagues are in
fact the ideal transmitter,
uh,
for democratic mores and values.
And I want to take an example
from a movie that I have,
which I'm very fond by the Cohen
brothers called the big Lebowski,
which is a movie about a bowling league,
or at least three gentlemen who take
their bowling in their bowling league very
seriously.
Uh,
the three of them are the
dude who is a stone Hippie,
uh,
Walter,
who's kind of a whacked out Vietnam vet
and Danny who's a last wave and they are
very,
very concerned with
getting in to the finals,
into the bone bowling tournament.
And in their way stands a man named Hayes
who's Cantana who it happens also to
be a sex offender.
And we're going to show,
I want to show a couple of clips from
this movie and I should warn you that
there is some very bad
language being used here.
So if you think that is
going to be offensive to you,
you should leave.
Uh,
we won't take more than about four,
four minutes or so.
And we're going to show a couple of
clips about the ethos of men bowling,
do
civic association,
the Eith,
the democratic ethos of Bowling Leagues.
And I would assume three
ideal democratic citizens.
Well,
I,
I did that as a little bit of a joke
at Professor Putnam's expense maybe,
but,
uh,
you know,
and I also really liked the movie
and it's also really hard to
follow something like that too,
I have to say.
But,
um,
uh,
obviously it seems,
it goes to show that civic
association alone is not enough,
uh,
to,
create a democratic citizens again,
otherwise smokey and the
dude and Walter would be,
uh,
you know,
perfect example of democratic citizens.
Tocqueville focuses on a third and other,
uh,
leg of the stool of democratic life and
that that is what he calls the spirit of
religion central again,
as the third and I,
and in in many ways very important prop
of the American democratic experience
and my Ra on my arrival
in the United States,
he observes,
it was the religious aspect of the
country that struck my eye first.
Very impressed with that.
And like other European visitors to the
United States both then as well as now
it's Tocqueville was deeply struck with
how democracy and religion walk seemed
to walk hand in hand with each other.
Precisely the opposite of
what has occurred in Europe,
where religion in democracy
or religion inequality,
we're long on a collision course.
What made,
uh,
the American,
encounter with democratic life?
A unique,
that is one of
Tocqueville's big questions.
In the first instance you could say,
uh,
or as Tocqueville notes that American
America is primarily a puritan democracy.
I see the whole destiny of America
contained in the first puritan who land on
its shore landed on its shores.
He says like the whole
human race in the first man.
Uh,
our experience was determined in,
in crucial ways by those are the,
by early puritanism.
Uh,
America was created by people with
strong religious beliefs and habits who
brought to the new world a suspicion
of government and a strong desire of
independence.
And this has set,
this has been the foundation
of the separation of church
and state that has done
so much both for religious
and political liberty.
And toke though drew from this
two very important consequences,
I think,
uh,
about religious life in America.
Uh,
the first,
uh,
is that the thesis has propounded by the
great philosophers of the enlightenment
of the 18th century and
still advanced in many,
uh,
you might say enlightened quarters today,
that religion will disappear,
uh,
as with the advance of modernity.
That is modernity,
advances,
uh,
religious life will disappear
I suppose in the 20th Century,
Mocks Vapor,
uh,
gave,
voice,
uh,
most prominently to that point of view
that would be a process of secularization
with maternity.
And it sort of gradual withering away,
uh,
of religious belief.
Tocqueville shows that
to be demonstrably false,
uh,
that religion will not simply disappear,
as modernity,
uh,
move moves forward and that the
enlightenment and it's contemporary heirs,
theorists of development and modernization
and so on have been altogether wrong
about their confident predictions
about the decline and withering away of
religious faith.
And secondly,
uh,
Tocqueville takes it to be a terrible
mistake to try to eliminate religion or
just secularized society altogether.
This is in fact,
probably a more controversial,
uh,
a very controversial claim.
It was his belief,
and again,
perhaps here he's influenced by Roussell
and the chapter on the civil civil
religion at the end of the social contract
that free societies rest on public
morality and morality cannot
be effective without religion.
It may be true that individuals can
derive moral guidance from reason alone,
but society's can't.
Uh,
and the danger of attempting to eliminate
religion from public life is that the
need or desire to believe will therefore
be transferred to other and far more
dangerous outlets.
Despotism he says,
can do without faith,
but freedom cannot,
uh,
very arresting sentence.
Despotism can do without faith but reason.
But,
but freedom cannot.
Religion is more necessary in a republic
and in a democratic country than any
other.
He says,
but why is religion
necessary to a republic?
Why does democracy require religion?
And here,
Tocqueville gives a variety of answers.
One persistent theme running throughout
his book as a whole is that only
religion can resist the tendency toward
materialism and to kind of low self
interest that he believes is
intrinsic to democratic ages.
And societies.
The principal business of religion,
he frequently,
uh,
rights,
is to purify as to regulate,
is to restrain the kind of ardent
desire for a wellbeing and particularly
material wellbeing that
becomes particularly prominent
during ages of equality.
It's one,
one reason,
but secondly,
or an addition,
Tocqueville operates,
uh,
I find it with a very interesting,
I might even call it
a metaphysic of faith,
uh,
that regard to religious belief as,
as a necessary component for human action.
Uh,
when religion is destroyed in a people,
this is Tocqueville.
When religion is destroyed
in a people doubt,
takes hold of the higher portion of the
intellect and half paralyzes all the
others.
Uh,
when,
uh,
religion is destroyed,
doubt takes over and it had,
it has a kind of paralyzing effect on
the will and our capacity for action.
And this paralysis of the will,
this inability to act as a condition
that later writers would choose to call
nihilism.
Faith is a necessary component for our
belief that we are free agents and not
simply the play thing of blind
forces and random causes.
Uh,
so to speak,
our beliefs about freedom.
And the dignity of the individual are
inseparable for him from religious faith
and it is light.
It is unlikely that these beliefs
about the dignity of the individual,
uh,
can survive without religion.
Uh,
just to take a contemporary
example of that,
think about the debates.
We have had a over such
things as cloning and uh,
the sense that many people have that,
uh,
the dignity of the individual,
which is often connected with,
uh,
a kind of religious belief,
sanctity of life.
The dignity of the individual is,
is somehow deeply violated
by these advances of,
of sort of scientific technology.
Uh,
that these are,
that religion remains a crucial
prop for our beliefs about,
uh,
human,
human dignity.
No more powerful challenge to the
enlightenment's faith in science and
scientific progress,
uh,
is can be found then in Tocqueville.
And one,
one final issue remains.
I would say Tocqueville often writes,
and I would say this is the dominant
tone of his writing on religion.
He often writes is if religion is only
valuable or valuable primarily for this
social function it serves.
Uh,
this is certainly consistent with
lots of things he says about religion.
He's only concerned about religion for
its social and political consequences
rather than from the deeper
truths of religious belief.
I view religion.
He says only from a purely
human point of view.
He says he's only looking
for its effect on society.
But I would ask how accurate is that
statement or does it describe a or
characterize all of Tocqueville's
views about religion?
I think not a,
let me just say why for a minute.
I think that sort of sociological or
functionalist reading of a religion that
he's interested only in it only for
its social effect is only part of
Tocqueville's very complex
attitude towards the subject.
Uh,
maybe you'll have a chance to
talk about this in your section.
Maybe you'll have an opportunity to
write about it at some other time.
But remember that Tocqueville was
not only a student of Roussel,
as he said in that letter to Louis De
[inaudible] that I mentioned last time,
his other two great sources of inspiration
or a Monte scare and a 17th century
French philosopher named Blaise Pascal.
A Pascal was a religious
philosopher who more than any other,
uh,
emphasize the emptiness of
knowledge without faith,
a man may be the rational animal,
uh,
but reason is somehow unable
to plum or reason is unable to,
to grasp the unfathomable
depths of the universe.
In one of his most famous statements,
Pascal said a vapor,
he says,
a vapor,
a drop of water is enough to kill him.
Speaking of,
speaking of here of us human humans,
a drop of water is enough to kill us.
Man is a read or read,
the weakest in nature.
But he is a thinking read.
We are,
we are weak.
we,
we think,
but,
but we are.
We are.
It is our weakness.
It is our dependence,
a sense of dependence that that
struck Pascal and Tocqueville.
You can find this in many,
several passages throughout the democracy.
Talk though I think discovered in Pascal,
a sense of kind of existential emptiness
and the incompleteness of life that
cannot be explained in
terms of reason alone.
There was also,
he felt something deeply hubristic uh,
about,
uh,
the way in which a conditions of equality,
foster,
uh,
this idea of,
of,
of rational self sufficiency Tocqueville's
purpose in many ways was to limit
reason to make room for faith.
And this is one of my favorite passages.
Let me just read it or sentenced
her to the short space of 60 years.
He writes almost as an aside,
the short space of 60 years,
we'll never confine the
whole imagination of man.
The incomplete joys of this world
will never suffice for his heart.
Incomplete joys of this world
In other words,
there is something we desire,
but beyond the here and now that only
faith can supply the sole exhibits a kind
of longing and desire for eternity and
to kind of discussed with the world and
the limits of physical existence.
Religion he goes on is only
a particular form of hope.
And it is as natural to the human
heart is hope itself only by a kind of
aberration of the intellect and with
the aid of a sort of moral violence
exercised on their own nature.
Do men stray from religious belief and
invincible inclination leads them back to
religion?
Disbelief is an accident.
Faith alone is the
permanent state of humanity.
Uh,
if anyone's interested,
that's on page two 84,
but no one can possibly read that
section and come away from Tocqueville by
thinking he had a,
had only a kind of functionalist
sociological view of religion,
concern with its effects on
human behavior and society,
uh,
disbelief as an accident.
Faith is the permanent condition of
humanity and only to a kind of moral
violence through the moral violence.
Uh,
Ken,
uh,
religious faith be,
be eliminated.
I think these passages show a much deeper,
almost metaphysical dimension
to Tocqueville start,
uh,
shows him to be a thinker like Plato
in many ways of enormous psychological
depth and subtlety,
uh,
and,
and insight.
But these are the three
features or three of the future.
I think the three central features that,
uh,
remain for him,
crucial to democracy,
uh,
local government,
civil association in what he
calls the spirit of religion
and yet obviously or is not well,
uh,
or as far from being well,
too often,
way too often we read,
uh,
democracy in America is if it were
simply a celebration of the democratic
experience in America.
It is not a,
and Tocqueville,
uh,
among other things is deeply
worried about the potential.
Mentioned briefly about this last time,
uh,
the,
the potential of democratic tyranny.
Uh,
why is there a belief or why,
why would one believe,
uh,
that,
that democratic government,
uh,
alone will eliminate various forms of
arbitrary rule in tyrannical government.
In fact,
it might create new forms of tyranny,
democratic tyranny of which
previous societies had been,
uh,
perhaps unaware.
This is an issue that he treats
twice in two important parts,
uh,
in,
in his work,
one in volume one,
the other,
in volume two.
I'm only going to,
I'm going to talk for a
little bit today about,
uh,
his account of tyranny of
the majority and volume wine.
And I'm going to save a part of the other
rest of the discussion for next week
when he talks about what he
calls democratic despotism
and the second part of
democracy in America and volume one,
he treats the,
what he calls the tyranny of the majority,
largely in terms you might say,
that are derived or
inherited from Aristotle.
And even the authors of the federalist
papers you remember in Aristotle's
politics,
uh,
Aristotle associated democracy with the
rule of the many rule of the many for
all kinds of peer purposes,
generally means rule of the poor,
uh,
and rule of the poor
for their own interest.
The danger with democracy
for Aristotle was it did,
it still represented a,
the tyranny of one class a of
society over the society of a whole,
the largest class ruling,
uh,
in its interests over the
minority democracy for the
ancients was always a form
of class struggle between
the rich and the poor.
And that was in many respects,
the way in which democracy came to be
viewed even by the federalist authors who
came up with their own solution to the
problem of democracy or what they called
a Republican government.
The problem of Republican government was
this problem of you might say majority
faction and their answer to the problem
of majority faction was in Madison's
term to enlarge the orbit
of government to make,
make societies and polities much
larger in order not to try to eliminate
faction,
but to increase them.
Uh,
by increasing the number of factions you
decrease the possibility that any one
of them will be able to represent or
exercise a kind of permanent majority,
uh,
control,
a kind of permanent,
a tyranny of the majority.
The greater the number of factions,
the less likelihood that any one of them
will be able to exercise despotic power
over national politics.
And this is a question that Tocqueville
returns to or turns two in that very
important chapter from book one called
the omnipotence of the majority in the
United States into f and its effects,
which is in many respects a response or
a re provides his reading and critique
of the classical or traditional
theory of democratic tyranny.
The U s constitution,
he talks about his enshrined,
the majority,
and it's opening preamble.
We the people it has
enshrined the majority,
even as it has sought to limit
the powers of the people.
And although Tocqueville devotes a
great deal of attention in volume one,
we're not really reading these sections.
I don't think they're all that
important for our purposes.
He spends a great deal of attention
simply sort of describing,
uh,
the,
the makeup of the federal constitution,
the structure of the
houses of governments.
So on one has to say he is far less
impressed than Madison or the federalist
authors were that the problem of
majority faction has been solved in,
in America.
Again,
the federalist authors following lock
and Montesquieu believed all that was
unnecessary or was separation of powers,
a system of representation,
a system of checks and balances that
this could serve as an effective check on
majority rule.
But Tocqueville was less certain of that.
It was less certain that these,
as it were,
institutional devices alone could
check what he calls the empire of the
majority,
the empire of the majority,
a term that he uses,
that he clearly has kind of theological
connotations denoting a kind of divine
omnipotence,
that the people have come to be
the ultimate or final authority.
And rather than regarding,
as it were,
the people in Madisonian terms,
simply as a kind of ongoing
shifting coalition of interests,
Tocqueville regarded the majority in
democratic societies as the power of the
majority is unlimited,
is unlimited and unstoppable legal
guarantees of minority rights,
he thought were unlikely to be effective,
uh,
in the face of mobilized public opinion.
Why does Tocqueville believe that or what,
what,
uh,
what led him to express
such skepticism about,
uh,
even American democracy's
inability to check?
Uh,
the prospect of democratic tyranny in
part I think talks to us answer was that
majority tyranny was inseparable from
the threats of revolutionary violence and
particularly charismatic demagogues in
military leaders like Napoleon in France.
Uh,
and,
uh,
and America's a counterpart
to Napoleon Andrew Jackson,
uh,
Napoleon,
was in France,
the man capable of mobilizing a,
the masters into fits of patriotic
zeal and to carry on a war.
And Jacksonian ism for him was simply,
uh,
looked like sort of the,
an American fault farm of Bonaparte
partism a military commander writing to
political power on the wings of popular
support more than anything else.
Tocqueville,
feared militarism combined with a
kind of unlimited patriotic fervor.
And it is in these respects,
you can begin to see,
uh,
some of the less,
the less ennobling features,
uh,
of the democratic experience and the
more ominous possibilities of democratic
rule.
The power of the majority says,
makes itself feared,
especially to the dominance
of the legislature.
He believed,
uh,
we could talk about whether this
belief is still valid or true.
He believed that the most,
again,
that democracy tends towards a kind of
legislative dominance of the legislatures
were the people's voice makes it's,
it's will most clearly known.
And by having short elections are short,
short cycles every two years,
uh,
in the House of Representatives,
it was a way of making sure
that the legislature's,
the house,
the houses,
uh,
are,
are very close to public
opinion and public control.
And he sees this,
uh,
these,
this is a dangerous thing.
This kind of legislative dominance,
uh,
that he sees is one farm,
in the way in which the tyranny
of the majority expresses itself.
But the most important and
the most memorable aspects
of tyranny of the majority
have less to do with these,
um,
institutional,
uh,
forms you might say.
Then it has to do with,
uh,
the way in which the empire,
again,
I'll use his term,
the empire of the majority makes
itself felt in the realm of thought and
opinion.
Uh,
the influence of the
majority over-thought.
Okay.
In an always startling
passage from the book,
Tocqueville remarks.
I know of no other country,
we're in general less independence of
mind in genuine freedom of discussion rain
than in America,
have no country where there was less
independence of mind and freedom of
discussion.
He is,
I suspect overstating the case.
But,
uh,
his argument here is that the dangers
to freedom of thought in a democracy do
not come from the threat
of an inquisition.
They do not come from
a something like that,
but they are exercised in more subtle
forms of exclusion and ostracism.
Tocqueville is perhaps in that passage,
one of the first and most perceptive
analysts of what today might be called the
power of political correctness to
control and to eliminate certain kinds of
ideas and opinions from being
thought it is the fear of ostracism.
In some sense,
the fear of being socially ostracized,
that,
uh,
the majority to through which the
majority exercises it's control and talk.
Those statement here,
uh,
is of course the persecution
can take many forms,
uh,
under a democratic,
people,
uh,
from the cruelest,
to the most mild.
Uh,
he gives various examples of the crueler
forms of the way in which the majority
has expressed itself itself.
In a lengthy footnote to the book,
uh,
for example,
he,
in this,
in,
in some of this these
parts he talks about,
uh,
he gives two examples.
One in which,
uh,
during the war of 1812,
he says there were,
uh,
there were some antiwar
journalists in Baltimore.
Maybe you read that passage who were,
uh,
who were taken out,
their,
their newspaper pressed was burned down.
And,
uh,
and they were,
I think they were hung.
He says,
this is the way in which kind of
Ma that mob mentality took over.
And he also uses the example of the way
in which black voters in the state of
Pennsylvania and in petite focuses
on this particularly have been
disenfranchised.
And he mentions Pennsylvania in particular
because Pennsylvania is a Quaker
state.
Uh,
that is to say a state where we're,
one would've thought liberal opinion
towards questions of racial justice would,
would have been most advanced.
And even there,
he says,
uh,
the majority,
constrain,
uh,
African American voters from
a free blacks from voting.
So these are ways in which,
uh,
again,
some,
some overt and cruel and
persecute persecutory others
milder and in through the
form of ostracism that
he wants to say that,
uh,
that the,
that the democratic,
uh,
sovereignty can exercise itself,
chains and executions or
the course instruments.
He writes that tyranny formerly employed.
But in our day,
civilization has perfected
despotism itself,
which seemed to have
nothing more to learn.
We have deaf perfected despotism.
He says under the absolute
government of one man,
despotism struck crudely at the body.
So to reach the soul,
no doubt,
thinking about the inquisition and
things like this in Spain and in parts of
Catholic Europe,
and he writes in the soul,
escaping from those blows
rose gloriously above it,
but he goes in democratic republics,
tyranny does not proceed in this way.
It leaves the body alone and
goes directly for the soul.
Well,
there's a wealth of,
of commentary.
Uh,
you might,
uh,
think about when you,
when you,
when you read that,
when you read that passage,
that's an implied there.
Um,
Oh God,
the terms moving so quickly,
so much more.
So those are the three f.
Uh,
so that's,
that,
that for Tocqueville is the,
is the,
is one of the other sides of,
uh,
of,
of the democratic experience.
And I,
again,
I want to return to a
piece of that on Wednesday,
next week rather Monday,
because I think you will see in volume
to Tocqueville has something of a change
of heart.
He doesn't become more optimistic.
In fact,
he becomes far more
pessimistic about this,
but there's certainly a change of tone,
uh,
in what Tocqueville has to
say about the potentiality of,
of,
uh,
of majority tyranny.
Well,
we had so much fun watching the movie.
Uh,
I didn't get a chance to,
there's,
there's a little more I wanted to say,
but it seems like a
good note to break on a,
I try to finish whatever I can with
Tocqueville on Monday and Wednesday and
going,
go try to wrap things up and tell you,
uh,
what you should be thinking about.
So,
uh,
anyway,
enjoy yourselves and
I'll see you next week.